would you say
economics is more art or science or
philosophy or even magic what is it
economics is interesting because it's
all of the above
to start with magic the notion that you
can make some change and simply
everyone's better off
that is a kind of modern magic that has
replaced old-style magic
it's an art in the sense that the models
are not very exact
it's a science in the sense that
occasionally propositions are falsified
are a few basic things we know yeah and
however trivial they may sound if you
don't know them
you're out of luck so all of the above
but from my outsider's perspective
economics
is sometimes able to formulate very
simple
almost like e equals mc squared general
models of how
our human society will function when you
do a certain thing
but it seems impossible or almost
way too optimistic to think that a
single formula or just a
set of simple principles can describe
the
behavior of billions of human beings
well with all the complexity that we
have involved
do you have a sense there's a hope for
economics to
to uh to have those kinds of physics
level descriptions and models of the
world or is it just our desperate
attempts as humans to make sense of it
even though it's
more desperate than uh than uh
rigorous and serious and actually
predictable like a like a
physics type science i don't think
economics will ever be very predictive
it's most useful for helping you ask
better questions
you look at something like game theory
well game theory never predicted
usa and ussr would have a war would not
have a war
but trying to think through the logic of
strategic conflict if you know game
theory
it's just a much more interesting
discussion
you